let's take a closer look at what
food technology brings us
technologies like
flash pasteurization improve the shelf life
of our food by protecting it from
harmful bacteria
food technology allows us
to replace the air inside
packaging to preserve  the taste the
natural color and texture of the
food
complementary antioxidants keep the ahly
members as fresh as possible and
for as long as possible while
preventing them from deteriorating and
preserving their essential qualities at
home we can benefit from a
modern and respectful fridge  of
the environment which not only
keeps food fresh and
crisp but which uses less
energy to achieve this in
short food technology
allows us to avoid this and preserve its in
europe food technology
respects the strictest standards
to guarantee  our safety to
preserve the freshness and taste of our
food and to maintain the strength of
our economy
food technology for
top food